Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE used the death
count from the hijacked 911 Flight 93 to minimize
the risk of shooting down the Chinese spy balloon.
Overland. And the crowd goes completely silent.
You have to see this. This is stunning,
stunning stuff. Marjorie Taylor GREENE and
a bunch of right wingers initially went after
Joe Biden by saying he's not going to have the
testicular fortitude. That's my word, not theirs
to shoot down the Chinese surveillance balloon.
As we know, Joe Biden eventually shot down the
Chinese surveillance balloon. And so Republicans
had to shift their tone, shift their message.
Some of them shifted to who cares? Any president
would have done it. But Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is shifting to. He didn't need to wait for the
balloon to go over water before shooting it down.
That was a sissy move. He should have shot it down
over land. And as proof as to how benign that
is. Think back to 911. Remember when there was
that crash? I mean, even describing it as a crash
when there was that crash. Nobody. I mean, yes,
everybody on the plane died, but nobody on the
ground died. It is so quiet as Marjorie Taylor
GREENE says, these disgusting things in this room.
The crowd was all jazzed up up until this point.
It goes so quiet that if somebody dropped a pin,
you would be able to hear it. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: She finally leaves the coast and
then, oh, they shot it down. The excuses that
were given on this were prophetic, absolutely
pathetic. They told us it was too risky. Oh,
it was too risky to shoot down the Chinese spy
plane. Do you know what a bunch of blond that is?
Unidentified: They said it's three school busses.
Speaker 2: Three school busses. Why? Okay. Well,
do you guys remember on 911 when
an airplane crash in Pennsylvania
and jetliner? Remember that, Wolf? It didn't kill
anybody on the ground. Killed everyone on board.
But it didn't kill silence instantly. Silence
anyone on the ground. So they want to tell all
of us that it was too risky to take down that
Chinese by one of our rural Idaho or Montana
or any of these other states or Alaska.
Speaker 1: Anyway, quite a bold analogy
to be making. But in the service of
attacking any decision made by Joe Biden,
anything is fair game for people like
Marjorie Taylor GREENE a disgusting person.
Usually I say a disgusting woman, and someone
wrote to me and said, David, sir, might you be
a misogynist? Because if a man does something
disgusting, you say, What a disgusting person.
But when Marjorie Taylor GREENE does something
disgusting, you say, What a disgusting woman.
I don't know. Should I say disgusting person?
She's definitely both. So far as we all know,
she's a woman in the in the in the
valiant battle against trans locusts,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE has drawn that line in
the sand. She is a woman, should I say? She's
a disgusting person or a disgusting woman? Let
me know. But disgusting certainly fits the bill.
Absolutely no tragedy she is unwilling to use
to her perceived advantage. We will have all
of these clips on our YouTube channel, YouTube.com
slash The David Pakman Show, And we will also have
these clips in Spanish now on the Spanish YouTube
channel YouTube.com slash at symbol David Pakman
Espanol. I know. It's like, isn't it Espanol?
But you can't in a URL have the thing over the
end. So it's David Pakman Espanol for the Spanish
channel. It's crazy. I know, but check it out.